first I want record point might like
yesterday you actually do have a look at
rainfall measurements like over the
course of India you have a grateful fell
in Sydney or whatever
I wondered you member read full vision
is so unusual you know if it were
totally now you can't measure it in
steel but actually usually and like if
you hear it or like the weather report
it
yeah ma'am they actually say oh we go 34
millimeters of rain today then you -
another percent a lot yeah this is a bit
weird I always saw this class change
because rain takes up like 3d space
that's volume or core capacity at least
right so why are they measuring it with
the same things that I mission lies with
it's not like rain arranges itself is
aligned so what's with that I would
general dumbasses yes because Russians
are very okay Maddie okay so I think you
can help me go to diversity but only a
Joel is example but it's just that
starts over here I'm going to draw
basically what it looks like
okay so you talk this is the still
another natural I choose to think is a
little grounder from here and it's true
if you go to a weather station you'll
see something that looks very very
solicitous and as the rain falls the
sooner gets fuller and football how when
they say old elevated they're measuring
how high the rain is gone now here's the
weird thing that the soil is always I'm
sentimental and you start to think about
it who decided who decided that this
thing here should be whatever size that
it is what if I change the size of it
what am i letting you get like a
different measuring is there some
companies inside of this appreciated
science all rainfall measuring things
and then I realized tonight I went to a
school where they they did you where the
missions were wonderful too but there is
not a state of time so that big even
though what to them are made by the same
company so at the same time they don't
have to be like this they don't even
have to be round beside this orchard or
another see just draw for me like a a
box
this
Oh
okay so she is my fish here's a
beautiful drop box which has water in it
as you can see now here's the thing if
on a day it rains and you've got the
ability in looks like something designed
to measure - work I just got something
right next to it which is a completely
different shape completely different
sign so what are there in the same place
amazingly they all have exactly the same
number of millimeters drawn on them and
it's right next to it you have like some
enormous pool like I grew up in my car
and it's like you know the size of this
room okay and if you had millimeter
marking on it your pool would also have
increased but exactly to say about as
all these tiny instruments even though
they're completely different shapes and
sizes
now the question is why why would the
number of millimeters be the same no
matter what instrument you use eagle so
here is a resistible R is only getting a
smaller area right there is a pool it's
like a lot bigger so you're getting a
lot more of it and then B - yeah very
much just imagine it's right suppose of
everything we got one millimeter print
just really one millimeter just picking
these people okay how much grain would
it take to make this thing go up by 1
billion and the answer is not very much
so it would go up a little bit now it
changed walrein
physically will read so they go up by
one millimeter right but because of the
object area right if you would
vertically for this it's wider it's
longer so therefore it collects more
rain it would collect the same all
you're ready to make it go what do this
and the same with a pool right because
it is so much larger again even though
it takes more water to remove the
needles to actually get it to move up
one millimeter well it is exactly that
same size that it needs to be Jesus so
even though it would make sense to
measure in a volume like mils or leaders
whether because this is kiss
no matter what you're measuring with
this is what they say so now how do
think your arm underneath your diagram
train we do actually want to work out we
want to work out a volume because you're
consuming what it's not enough to say oh
we got certainly your vision or brain
you need to learn how much is actually
in your tank that you can say use so
what are your plans for it so we want to
work out volume of water generally what
we're seeking that is collected by house
if you've ever seen or litter house
which has a rainwater tank right
basically all that's happening is just
like we have got it right and I got it
basically I just spill out into onto the
papers their gutters are design so all
of the water collected by the entire
roof is funneled into the tape okay so
if you want to work that out well
actually now it makes a difference
whether you've got a smaller or bigger
feet bigger house bigger root you
collect more water does that make sense